[ __ ] message oh man do not get me
started on the Mexicans hey I just say
it
they hold the goddamn economy together
you know what man
damn straight if 12% of the Mexicans
live this country stop working just 12%
USA was shut down but I don't even care
who hears me
they worked our asses off and they got
strong family very essential immigrants
hey speaking of immigrants
how about damn Asians [ __ ] you know what
brother you want to lock that foods and
you better spam back cuz I got something
I want to say about those [ __ ]
yeah I got three words for you it's
studious hardworking industrious damn
straight
Asians are the highest income best
educated and the fastest little racial
group in the u.s. somebody mm+
got the highest percentage of college
graduates in the country good for them
maybe this makes me sound racist but
those [ __ ] they're gonna save
the country there it is he said you went
and said it I just said I just came
right the [ __ ] out said he was it
everyone's mine but I'm the one who said
it
hey and you know what while we're at it
I'm gonna break my spine tip-tap dancing
wincing prancing around the elephant in
the room
Black's [ __ ] blacks [ __ ] blacks
you know what you're doing doing bed yo
open up the floodgates now I'm a friend
release the Kraken goddamn victims of
institutionalized racism just to become
one of those guys start dressed they're
just true right there that's this
historical back mate Katie Margot
oh how about the Indians [ __ ] Native
Americans I don't know if I give trouble
these days they're saying something like
this but they were here first
oh it may be unpopular but it's true we
came to this country and we steamrolled
on in and we genocided them I mean he'll
we hold something are you not telling me
that's not bad for a non-alcoholic beer
and I bet it all all right I gotta go
home take care of my kids how many of
them you got now
just adopted the 11th Oh can't help
myself me and that's always what happens
when you volunteer for the earthquake
relief in Haiti
what you don't let's go dude
no my wife makes 2/3 and what I'm
thinking what y'all got the same job man
that's just patently unfair that's right
both librarians nerds
you all right I'm okay
you